madame monsieur bonsoir l'événement
politique c'est dans quelques minutes
sur france 2 avec l'interview du premier
ministre qui sera interrogé par l'ats
richard beau et par alain djamen sur le
programme du gouvernement dans le coffre
à mort sur sa politique vis-à-vis des
jeunes sur la corruption les affaires et
aussi les tout derniers soubresauts
politiques notamment dans la majorité et
d'emballage labrosse wars est en forme
et seulement
tout va bien pour vous vers 20h20 donc
avec mes deux confrères tout de suite le
reste de l'actualité à l'étranger tout
d'abord des coups de canon ont été tirés
aujourd'hui à la frontière
israélo-jordanienne mais cette fois pas
pour tuer mais au contraire pour
célébrer la paix entre les deux pays et
cela dans un décor hollywoodien en plein
désert sous l'oeil bienveillant de bill
clinton le roi hussein et itzhak rabin
ont signé l'accord mettant fin à
quarante six années d'état de guerre
entre leurs deux peuples
récit de notre envoyé spécial charles
enderlin au début les journalistes
israéliens trouvait cette cérémonie
plutôt ennuyeuse mais au fil des minutes
ils se sont laissé prendre par les
boîtiers
en découvrant parmi les spectateurs le
père du soldat israélien assassiné par
le hamas il ya douze mois
en entendant pour la première fois les
hymnes nationaux joué par les deux
fanfares militaires en voyant c'est tout
de même surprenant
une unité d'artillerie mixte israélienne
et jordanienne tiré 21 août kent une
atmosphère chaleureuse qui correspond
aux nouvelles relations entre les deux
pays cette paix là je compte sur la
coopération économique et politique
c'est à qui le roi rychen notre cadeau
au peuple et aux générations futures
tous les enfants d'abraham se
souviendront de ce jour il s'attaquera
been a lui aussi évoqué un avenir
meilleur qui fait désormais construire
réalisé qu'il la grande révolution du
trop sur lui mais la paix a de nombreux
ennemis et bill clinton a promis son
soutien à israël et à la jordanie face
aux forces de la terreur
ils vont tenter de l'érotisme après la
cérémonie en compagnie de bill et de mme
hillary clinton qui fixera qu'il est
arabe il est sans qualités julien aqaba
chez le roi hussein
et dans moins de deux semaines cette
frontière s'ouvrira non plus seulement
touristes étrangers et aux israéliens
qu'ils voudront visiter la jordanie
seul absent de marque à ces festivités
yasser arafat qui n'avaient pas été
invités
les palestiniens craignent que le
rapprochement entre israélien et
jordanien ne se fasse sur leur dos une
grève générale a été massivement suivie
aujourd'hui à jérusalem est et en
cisjordanie occupée
et cela pour protester contre ce traité
de paix reportage de notre envoyé
spécial
olivier lerner le mouvement intégriste
le hamas menace de frapper encore et le
fait savoir
sur ces images tournées hier soir on
voit bien la détermination de ces hommes
que rien ne semble pouvoir arrêter
jérusalem après deux visages aujourd'hui
côté pile les palestiniens ils ne se
sont pas levés pour écouter l'hymne is
really la cérémonie diffusée à la
télévision a provoqué chez eux une
réaction de rejet atmosphère glaciale et
glauque dans jérusalem est d'ordinaire
si colorée nos boutiques sont fermées
parce qu'on estime qu'avec cet accord
les jordaniens vont nous voler tous nos
droits sur jérusalem
ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on fait la paix
jerusalem côté face c'est israel yens
avait été touché par autobus qui a
explosé sur 19 mercredi dernier ligne
jordanien l'a fait craquer je suis sûr
qu'il y aura moins d'attentats je suis à
fond pour l'appel dans les quarante
cimetière militaire du pays
dix huit mille soixante quatre tombes
ont été fleuris des roses rouges pour
cette paix israël au jordanienne qui
devrait comme la ville le premier
ministre israélien permettre aux déserts
minet qui séparait les deux pays de
refleurir et se transformer en oasis la
délicate question du statut de jérusalem
avait été soulevée ce matin par yasser
arafat
lors de sa rencontre au caire avec le
président clinton
de son côté le président américain s'est
déclaré satisfait de l'engagement pris
par le président de l'autorité
palestinienne à combattre le mouvement
intégriste palestinien hamas en france
toujours les affaires avec le résultat
de l' expertise sur le coût de
construction de la villa tropézienne de
gérard longuet selon le président du
parti républicain le rapport des experts
établi de façon incontestable que cette
villa n'a pas été sous payés précision
tout de suite avec thierry kurt et quel
prix pour cette maison de saint-tropez
gérard longuet at il oui ou non
bénéficier d'une ristourne
exceptionnelle de la part de
l'entrepreneur comme le pense le juge
van ruymbeke ou l'at-il payé à sa juste
valeur
le rapport d expertise demandée par
l'ancien ministre semble être en sa
faveur
les deux experts avaient pour mission d'
estimer le prix de construction de la
maison à sa livraison en janvier 89
il arrive à un chiffre de 3 millions
cent cinquante six mille francs alors
que la facture présentée à l'époque par
l'entreprise sereda était de deux
millions huit cent quatre-vingt treize
mille francs une différence disent des
experts qui s'explique par un excédent
en matériaux et par certaines erreurs
commises par l'entreprise elle même
bref conclut les experts compte tenu des
travaux de finition le coût du mètre
carré de la villa de gérard longuet aidé
environ 9500 francs
un prix comparable à celui du marché
l'instruction refermerait ce dossier
alors je demande à monsieur le garde des
sceaux de ne pas donner à la justice
ridicule d'ouvrir une instruction
on ne servirait à rien de fermer le
dossier un prix qui pourtant ne tient
pas compte des frais de déplacement des
ouvriers depuis le département de la
meuse
l'entrepreneur a donc de toute façon
perdu de l'argent sur ce chantier
mais un prix qui reste loin de
l'estimation du juge van ruymbeke qui
était de 4 millions 200 mille francs
les questions que je pose la justice
concerne aussi le mode de financement de
cette maison est là le rapport ne répond
pas à cette question
invité de france 2 à partir de 20h20
edouard balladur reviendra notamment sur
ces affaires
à noter ce dernier sondage csa à
paraître demain dans le parisien
un sondage qui va sans doute un peu
fâché de la balladur parmi les électeurs
de la majorité 38% des sondés le désigne
en effet comme le principal fauteur de
troubles alors que 32% site jacques
chirac
cet autre information qui va peut-être
mettre un peu de baume au coeur du
premier ministre valéry giscard
d'estaing a accepté son invitation à se
rendre à matignon débattre de la
cohésion de la majorité
enfin jacques delors a indiqué qu'il
resterait à bruxelles à la tête de la
commission au moins jusqu'au 25 janvier
le tribunal de grande instance de paris
a examiné aujourd'hui le litige
financier qui oppose bernard tapie au
crédit lyonnais
au centre des débats une dette de 1
milliard 300 millions de francs dont la
banque réclame le remboursement immédiat
mais que bernard tapie affirme couvertes
par un accord de remboursement sur cinq
ans qu'ils demandent à la justice de
faire respecter afin de pouvoir
récupérer ses meubles saisi sur place
pour france 2 dominique verdeilhan
bernard tapie sur les marches d'un
palais de justice
l'image n'est pas nouvelle mais vaut
mieux ne pas la rater seulement bernard
tapie ne viendra pas et photographes et
cameramans resteront dehors pourtant à
l'intérieur il est question d'un divorce
entre une banque d'état et son client
après 17 ans de relation et dans tout
divorce sans consentement mutuel
il faut un fautif pour tapie il s'agit
de jean peyrelevade actuel pdg du crédit
lyonnais
pour l'avocat le tapis jean peyrelevade
s'est livré à une campagne de 10
roman en médiatisant la saisie des biens
de bernard tapie
ce fut poursuit l'avocat une tentative
de réconciliation avec l'opinion
publique les clients fuyait il fallait
réagir
pour les avocats du crédit lyonnais et
bernard tapie est un piètre gestionnaire
qui n'a pas respecté ses engagements et
qui a surtout cacher ses ennuis fiscaux
12 millions de prendre redressement
pour le procureur les torts sont certes
partager mais le protocole est caduque
autrement dit le crédit lyonnais était
dans son droit
le tribunal devrait rendre son jugement
fin novembre si le crédit lyonnais
condamné bernard tapie retrouvera ses
meubles
si en revanche le député est débouté il
devra payer sa dette
le non-paiement de celle ci pourrait
entraîner d'autres procédures qui
pourraient déboucher éventuellement sur
une faillite personnelle de bernard
tapie incompatible avec un mandat
électoral seulement quand la justice
aura définitivement trancher ce
contentieux
les électeurs se seront rendues
probablement aux urnes depuis longtemps
au centre de ce règlement de comptes à
ok tribunal l'estimation du patrimoine
de bernard tapie et plus
particulièrement d'un mobilier qui a
beaucoup voyagé fils boisserie
feuilleter le numéro de novembre de
l'objet d'art c'est un petit peu comme
se promener dans un musée le musée tapis
on y découvre des bijoux de l'art
italien
un salon louis xiv tout un périple dans
le mobilier du xviiie siècle un voyage
imaginaire puisque ces photos prises il
ya cinq ans date d'avant les
déménagements
si l'on comprend pourquoi les
connaisseurs parle de tapis comme d'un
collectionneur hors du commun
bien malin qui pourrait statuer avec
certitude sur la valeur de ces biens
de ce point de vue là c'est toujours la
valse des étiquettes dans les
estimations
la première celle de l'expert jean
pierre dit les allées jusqu à 517
millions
sa seconde fourni au début du litige
avait fondu de moitié entre 34 et 51
millions assène début août les experts
britanniques de christie's
une semaine plus tard ceux de sotheby's
font encore tomber la fourchette de
quelques millions aujourd'hui bernard
tapie donne son estimation personnelle
entre 120 et 130 millions autant dire
qu'on est loin des chiffres initiaux et
que les remboursements au crédit
lyonnais s'annonce délicat certes il
le fossé à l'hôtel particulier et les
sociétés de tapis mais avec cela il
faudra aussi rembourser le fisc et les
douanes etc à main et comme un problème
n'arrive jamais seul bernard tapie se
voit confronté à deux autres accusations
par le crédit lyonnais
celle d'avoir détourné une partie de son
mobilier avant la saisie est celle
d'avoir remplacé trois toiles par des
faux grossiers l'intéressé conteste mais
la banque préfère demander son avis au
juge alain carignon qui saura vendredi
s'il retrouve ou non la liberté a été
interrogé pour la troisième fois sur le
fond du dossier par le juge courroye
désormais vous le voyez sous haute
protection policière
une audition qui a duré plus de trois
heures et sur laquelle les avocats du
ministre démissionnaire n'ont pas voulu
faire de commentaire à l'origine des
graves ennuis du maire de grenoble
l'attribution du marché de l'eau à la
lyonnaise des eaux attributions dont la
justice soupçonne qu'elle n'a pas été
sans contrepartie personnel pour alain
carignon ce soir dans un communiqué la
lyonnaise des eaux dément formellement
tout pacte avec la ville de grenoble
contrairement aux accusations portées
hier dans libération par patrick tulle
l'ancien directeur de cabinet d'alain
carignon deux grands groupes se
partagent en france le marché de l'eau
la générale des eaux et la lyonnaise des
eaux de groupes extrêmement puissants
financièrement à titre indicatif la
générale des eaux a versé tout à fait
légalement est tout à fait
officiellement près de 14 millions de
francs partis politiques en 93 et la
lyonnaise des eaux
plus de 7 millions et demi de francs
enquête frédéric roth à un des hommes
les plus puissants de france est aussi
l'un des plus discrets il aura fallu
qu'un juge de l'île de la réunion le
convoque dans le cadre d'une enquête
locale mettant en cause son groupe la
cge pour que guy dejouany s'expose
devant une caméra
il est dit-on l'un des meilleurs
connaisseurs de la carte politique
française normal
la vocation de sa société depuis un
siècle c'est de prendre en charge la
gestion de l'eau des communes dans son
giron
un quart des villes françaises les plus
grosses lyon toulouse et nice l'eau
n'est aujourd'hui qu'une des activités
parmi d'autres le groupe composé de 2300
filiale s'occupe de travaux publics
c'est le deuxième groupe européen de
chauffage de déchets de nettoyage
gestion des parkings bref de tous et
possède même un réseau de téléphone et
de télévision par câble
un seul point noir ou ce groupe prospère
l'immobilier la société phoenix a perdu
cette année 8 milliards de francs à la
tête de la lyonnaise des eaux jérôme
monod 64 ans son groupe n'a évidemment
pas les mêmes clients classés ge
diversification dans le bâtiment avec le
rachat il ya quatre ans de dumez
lyonnaise et cge s'octroie avec bouygues
et saint gobain 80% du chiffre
d'affaires lié à l'eau potable mais
cette concentration pose problème le
partage du marché des os entraîne des
dérapages contracte trop longue
conditions draconiennes augmentation ici
et là du prix de l'eau dérapages
politiques avec les affaires de
corruption tout genre à la lyonnaise
comme la cge
on navigue en eaux troubles après la
bataille de loos ldr la cour de justice
européenne de luxembourg à rejeter la
demande du gouvernement français de
différer l'ouverture de certaines lignes
aériennes à la concurrence d'air france
ou des rats terre en principe dès demain
lé liaison orly toulouse et orly
marseille seront donc ouvertes à la
concurrence
précisions avec antoine cormery orly
toulouse orly marseille deux lignes très
rentables qui était jusqu'à présent la
chasse gardée des reins terre une
situation de monopole que le
gouvernement voulait prolonger mais la
cour de justice européenne a tranché
ces lignes doivent être ouverte
immédiatement aux autres compagnies
c'est la loi de la concurrence
européenne signée par la france il ya
deux ans ces cinq patrons de petites
compagnies qui ont fondé cette semaine
un comité de défense ont donc gagné leur
pari d'accéder au ciel français et le
ministre perdu le sien il faut que des
notions aussi forte pour la france que
le service public que l'aménagement du
territoire soit respectée la
concentration de la concurrence avec des
petits amis en nombre gênant les
riverains sur les soldes une des plus
rentables n'est pas une vision d'intérêt
général
la décision européenne permet une
ouverture des lignes marseille et
toulouse
dès demain les compagnies sont prêtes
n'est pas le ministère qui leur impose
maintenant un dossier de candidatures
une procédure de sélection qui devrait
retarder de trois mois les premiers
l'âge les journalistes de radio france
ont reconduit leur grève pour 24 heures
demain ils se prononceront à bulletin
secret sur les toutes dernières
propositions salariales du médiateur
l'organisation greenpeace parle de
désastre écologique majeure en raison
d'une fuite depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant d'un oléoduc dans le grand
nord russe
l'équivalent d'au moins 2 millions de
baril de pétrole se seraient déversés
dans les rivières et dans la toundra
soit huit fois la quantité de pétrole
déversée lors du naufrage de l'exxon
valdez sur les côtes de l'alaska chiffre
tout à fait minimiser côté autorités
russes où l'on affirme au contraire
qu'il n'y a aucun danger de catastrophe
écologique
sorti aujourd'hui sur les grands écrans
de france et de navarre du film qui a
obtenu la palme d'or au tout dernier
festival de cannes
pulp fiction réalisé par quentin
tarantino
une comédie polar au ton décalé en
hommage à la série b et aux romans bon
marché des années 40
reportage de philippe montoise y ait de
la pulpeuse pascal deschamps qui n'est
pas une fiction
sale gosse gratifie à 32 ans d'une palme
d'or comptines tarantino encore inconnu
il ya deux ans fait un carton aux états
unis avec pulp fiction sorti cette
semaine un ramassis zhang sphère
personnage mythique des pulp magazines
les romans à quat'sous américains dont
tarantino a fait grande consommation
film violent certes mais une violence
passée à la moulinette de la dérision
je ne supporte pas la violence dans la
réalité mais elle m'éclate quand je la
vois sur un écran ce n'est pas un
problème comme waddle médecin ni de dire
que pour moi être attaquées mangé par un
requin dans la réalité c'est une
tragédie mais j'adore les dents de la
mer pour là parce que je ne suis pas
dans l'eau en train de me faire bouffer
les fesses par un requin mais je suis
dans une salle de cinéma
je regarde une super histoire et je me
prends une claque alors vous deux vous
allez me prendre tous ces produits et
nettoyer l'intérieur de la voiture
vous me fait ça vite vite vite et sur la
banquette arrière vont me ramasser tous
les six éclats d'os et tous les bouts de
cervelle et vous me direz tout ça
nettoyez mois les tapis et les poussins
bons coups mais non ajouté pas c'est pas
la peine est inutile de faire du zèle
nettoyer tout ce qui se voit ça suffira
vous aller nettoyer à fond toute la
merde du pare brise des vies et de la
lunette arrière et dont j'ai bien de
sang par terre tarantino est sans doute
le cinéaste le plus cinéphile de sa
génération son film regorge de
références vous aviez dix secondes sont
reconnaître la séquence qui a inspiré
celle ci car tarantino loueur de
cassettes vidéo à los angeles pendant
dix ans et nouri de milliers de vieux
films parmi lesquels des français
tiennent la vedette
ce que j'aime dans ses films à bout de
souffle et qui taillent ne tirait pas
sur le pianiste
c'est qu'il s'inspire du genre des films
noirs genre inventé aux états unis as à
l'appel mais en même temps il le
réinvente complètement cette fais ce que
tu veux mais que ce soit drôle
réinventer le genre c'est ce qu'il a
fait lui aussi loin des clichés
alors vous adorerez paul frictionne
pourquoi parce que vous n'êtes pas en
train de vous faire éclater à servel à
coups de magnum dans un tripot sordide
mais vous êtes dans une salle de cinéma
et pulp fiction c'est une sacrée claque
bon anniversaire à françois mitterrand
qui fête aujourd'hui son 78e
anniversaire le dernier à l'élysée
l'horoscope du parisien indique pour
ceux dont c'est l'anniversaire
aujourd'hui un prochain changement
d'orientation dans leur vie
professionnelle peut être vers la fin du
mois de mai goldman mais françois
mitterrand fêtera samedi les 70 ans de
son épouse danielle et leurs noces d'or
vendredi fin de ce journal dans un
instant l'interview du premier ministre
suivi de madame le proviseur est bas les
masques
vers minuit le dernier journal catherine
ceylac demain gérard leclerc pour les
quatre vérités à 7h50 recevra simone
veil bonne fête aux dimitri dans un
instant la météo avec sophie davant et
le retour du soleil
hélas provisoire à demain 20h très très
bonne soirée merci